Bonjour , je vais parler avec un air dramatique pendant toute la vidéo.
C'est faux !
Aujourd'hui on va parler d'un truc assez sérieux mais ...
vous allez voir pourquoi je tenais à vous en parler et
vous en faites pas je vais pas faire de discours bateau
et chiant, euh, j'ai vraiment envie de vous apprendre des choses
et de vous expliquer un peu mon point de vue là-dessus
et que ce soit enrichissant pour tout le monde.
Il y a plusieurs jours, j'ai reçu un mail d'une association, euh...
qu'une maman avait contactée parce que sa fille
s'est retrouvée dans l'une de mes vidéos où je réagis à des vidéos
malaise ou qui font rire, appelez ça comme vous voulez.
En fait c'est une association que tu peux appeler
quand y a un problème quelconque avec ton enfant et que tu sais pas trop comment gérer.
Ils t'apportent de l'aide là-dessus et
la maman a dit à l'association que depuis que sa fille s'est retrouvée sur Internet
elle était un peu en dépression.
Alors bien-sûr c'est une vidéo qui avait déjà fait un buzz de ouf sur Internet
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'elle s'est retrouvée dans ma vidéo
mais je suis pas pardonnable pour autant dans le sens où j'ai quand même donné de l'importance à cette vidéo
et ça a quand même fait découvrir cette vidéo à des personnes qui ne l'avaient pas vue.
Donc je m'en veux.
Voilà, tout simplement, et je tenais à m'excuser à cette personne et à sa maman.
On a fait ce qu'il fallait pour que ça aille mieux.
C'est entièrement ma faute, j'ai pas été responsable.
J'ai pas pris conscience de l'impact que ça pouvait avoir sur la vie de quelqu'un de le mettre dans sa vidéo
et j'ai surtout pas pris conscience du comportement que certaines personnes pouvaient avoir vis-à-vis des vidéos de ce genre.
Voilà, ça c'est pour la partie badante
et ce qui fait que je vous parle de ça aujourd'hui.
Là où je veux en venir c'est que sur Internet y a pas mal de vidéos où des gens sont dans des situations un peu humiliantes
ou des situations dans lesquelles on a pas envie d'être.
Et c'est ça qui rend le truc drôle: c'est la situation, ok?
Donc on regarde la vidéo, ça nous fait marrer
On se dit "putain c'est trop drôle, la situation est épique".
Euh, y a toujours un événement, tu t'y attends pas, et ça te fait encore plus marrer.
Bref, y a des gens qui, en voyant ces vidéos-là, euh, vont juste se marrer et passer à d'autres vidéos.
Voilà, c'est des gens, des gens comme moi, des gens comme pleins d'entre vous, c'est sûr.
Mais, y a des gens qui ont besoin, en plus de rire devant la vidéo,
d'aller voir la personne et de se moquer d'elle en direct.
De l'insulter, de lui dire "t'es moche", enfin des trucs gratuits qui n'ont, fin ça a aucun sens de faire ça.
Voire même, euh, de retrouver la personne dans la vraie vie
et de poster des lettres dans sa boîte aux lettres, de toquer, de se moquer, de casser une vitre de la maison,
Fin ça peut aller vraiment super loin.
C'est ce qu'on appelle du
harcèlement.
Voilà y a des gens qui ont besoin, après avoir vu une vidéo
d'aller harceler la personne.
Alors je voudrais vous dire déjà que je cautionne pas du tout
ce genre de comportement
et que si des gens d'entre vous ont fait ça
et bah franchement vous avez déconné et ne le refaites plus jamais.
Vous n'avez aucune idée de l'impact que ça peut avoir
sur la vie de quelqu'un
parce que vous êtes pas seuls à le faire.
Y a pleins de gens qui vont le faire.
Quand c'est une personne, deux personnes, trois personnes
qui t'envoient une petite insulte, un petit message humiliant
ça fait chier, mais tu passes au-delà.
Quand ça commence à être des centaines de personnes
tous les jours sur une durée très longue
là, ton moral commence à être sérieusement affecté
et ça mène des gens au suicide.
Je reçois chaque semaine des mails de gens qui sont en réelle dépression alors qu'ils ont 11, 12, 13, 15 ans, 16 ans
et ils sont en dépression comme un adulte de 40 ans fait quand il a vécu énormément de choses.
Là, on parle quand même d'adolescents et qui en sont arrivés là juste parce que des gens les harcèlent en fait.
Du coup je suis pas psychologue, je suis pas assistante sociale, je peux pas faire du cas par cas vis-à-vis de ça
et je préfère faire de la prévention comme je fais là
qu'agir quand c'est trop tard en fait,
pour faire prendre conscience aux gens de ce que c'est le harcèlement
avant qu'eux-mêmes ne deviennent des harceleurs sans même s'en rendre compte.
Pour certains, la frontière entre les petits clashs, l'amusement, on se vanne etc...
et l'harcèlement
elle est un peu floue.
Quand quelqu'un n'est pas un ami proche de toi et que tu te moques tous les jours de lui pour les mêmes raisons
ça a vraiment un impact psychologique sur cette personne.
Et il faut s'en rendre compte, c'est terrible.
Et ce que je trouve horrible, maintenant (et j'ai beaucoup de mal avec les réseaux sociaux pour ça)
c'est que c'est vraiment rentré dans...
le coeur des gens en fait.
Ils ont vraiment besoin d'avoir un Twitter, besoin d'avoir un Facebook, besoin d'avoir Instagram
et de partager toute leur vie là-dessus.
Et le problème avec ça c'est que
autant ça part d'une bonne intention je trouve les réseaux sociaux
autant les gens en ont fait un peu n'importe quoi.
Et j'ai l'impression que ça fait plus de mal que de bien aujourd'hui.
Maintenant, quelqu'un qui se fait traquer à l'école, en cours,
ok, il va en cours, on se moque de lui toute la journée etc...
Il rentre chez lui, avant - nos parents - quand ils rentraient chez eux,
ils étaient tranquilles, ils étaient dans leur petit monde,
ils voyaient leurs potos autour d'eux, etc, y avait pas de soucis.
Maintenant, la personne quand elle rentre, elle va sur Internet
et, des fois, le harcèlement continue sous forme de "cyber-harcèlement"
via Internet, et la personne n'est jamais tranquille.
Vous vous rendez compte?
Tu sors de chez toi, t'es pas tranquille. Tu rentres chez toi, tu vas sur Internet pour te changer les idées et t'es encore pas tranquille.
J'ai vu les effets que ça pouvait avoir sur la vie des gens
et franchement, c'est terrible. C'est terrible.
Si vous aviez lu ces mails que je reçois, que je lis
et qui me foutent, euh, le cafard,
et je me dis "mais putain mais comment c'est possible?"
sincèrement vous seriez choqués. Vous seriez vraiment choqués.
Pour revenir aux réseaux sociaux, je trouve ça terrible ce besoin de partager sa vie, ce besoin
en fait ce besoin de satisfaire son égo virtuel.
Y a un égo virtuel.
Y a des battles de followers "ouais j'pèse plus que toi j'ai plus de followers" etc
À la base, les réseaux sociaux c'est pas censé apporter des problèmes
c'est juste censé te mettre en relation avec des gens qui ont les mêmes centres d'intérêts que toi.
C'est censé regrouper les gens autour de choses qu'ils aiment.
Bon, c'est la vision utopique du truc bien-sûr
ou même partager des infos facilement.
Par exemple, en 1789, la Révolution française ça aurait été autre chose s'il y avait eu Twitter
ça se serait fait en deux jours! (rires)
Y a une capacité à se mobiliser et à agir, qui est vraiment exceptionnelle avec Twitter, etc...
Bah regardez, Jérome Jarre par exemple récemment,
ce qu'il a fait pour la Somalie c'est juste génial et c'est l'illustration parfaite de ce qu'on peut réussir à faire avec les réseaux sociaux.
Prenez du recul par rapport au monde virtuel
n'oubliez jamais que c'est censé vous apporter que du kiff.
Si, quand vous allez sur Twitter/Facebook etc
vous subissez les choses, vous êtes mal
vous avez des gens qui disent "eh t'es moche" et ça vous blesse, vraiment ça vous blesse
et bah arrêtez, prenez du recul.
Allez avec vos potes que vous vous êtes faits via le Net,
Allez sur Skype juste avec eux, jouez juste avec eux,
passez le temps juste avec eux,
mais ne vous faites pas de mal.
C'est un peu gaga ce que je dis, ou ça peut paraître un peu évident pour certaines personnes
mais croyez-moi, ça ne l'est pas pour tout le monde
et je préfère le souligner parce que, mine de rien, y a beaucoup de gens qui subissent du cyber-harcèlement tous les jours,
peut-être même certains sans même s'en rendre compte, en se disant que c'est normal, que c'est Internet, que...
Mais nan, c'est pas normal.
C'est pas parce que les gens sont anonymes
et que du coup ils se lâchent complètement sur le Net vis-à-vis des autres et qu'ils les défoncent
que c'est normal.
Nan, c'est pas normal, pas normal du tout p*tain.
On devrait pas accepter ça et dire qu'Internet c'est comme ça, faut s'y faire.
Nan, faut pas s'y faire, faut juste qu'on change un peu nos comportements,
qu'on arrête d'être des gros beaufs de merde, aigris, qui critiquent tout
et qui descendent des gens pour rien,
et qu'on prenne un peu conscience des conséquences que ça a sur les autres.
Bref, si quelqu'un autour de vous se fait harceler, n'hésitez pas à lui apporter de l'aide.
Euh, je mettrai un numéro dans la description qui est le numéro officiel quand on subit du harcèlement
C'est des gens qui t'aident, qui te conseillent
qui, voilà, vraiment ça aide,
vraiment si vous êtes dans cette situation n'hésitez pas.
Je suis désolé pour tous ceux qui m'ont envoyé des mails mais j-je suis pas psychologue,
je suis pas, euh, bah, j-je sais même pas quoi vous dire en fait, je sais pas par où commencer.
Donc je préfère agir à m a manière en faisant de la prévention comme je fais là
et puis vous, je vous redirige vers des services qui ont été mis en place
euh, et qui sont très efficaces.
Donc n'hésitez pas à faire appel à ces services si ça va pas.
Bref, n'acceptons pas le harcèlement,
arrêtons de trouver ça "normal", on peut se clasher, on peut s'envoyer des vannes, on peut se marrer, c'est ça qui est bien aussi dans la vie
Mais quand l'on tombe dans le harcèlement, et c'est facile de tomber dans le harcèlement : Cela n'a plus rien de cool !
Et il y a des gens qui se tuent à cause de cela !
Je peux vous sortir des chiffres : il y a 3 à 4 personnes qui se suicident chaque année à cause du harcèlement, Il y a 22% des gens harcelés qui n'en parlent pas
Il y en a aussi beaucoup qui subissent du harcèlement et qui n'en n'ont même pas conscience, qui pense que c'est normal et que tout le monde est dans cette situation. Non!
Bref, Soyez sympa avec les autres ! Amusez-vous, clashez-vous, faites ce que vous voulez !
Mais ne brisez pas des vies bêtement !
Prenez conscience de vos actes, comme aujourd'hui je prends conscience de ma responsabilité quand je mets quelqu'un dans une vidéo et je réagis à cette vidéo et que je réagis à sa vidéo
Et que cela donne de mauvaise idées à d'autres personnes et que je n'ai pas vu le truc venir et que je m'en veux à mort